[Music]
our own cooking confidence coach nanny
buffy is back in studio thanks to
chapman automotive the sponsors of this
segment today we are learning how to
make midnight pasta and i have to tell
you i'm so excited this is our very
first segment together i want to give
you a welcome i know i know it's our
first time i'm always jealous you get to
cook with everyone else but today today
it's us we're making pasta so there are
usually when we do this because we're
talking about cooking confidence and
coaching uh people including yourself is
that we always start with a nanny bubbe
tidbit a lesson to be learned and then
we cook with it to see addition how it's
utilized so today we're talking about
seasoning pasta water okay right so with
every good dish that you're making we do
a combination of salt fat and acid when
it comes to pasta salting the water is
the most important thing so the one
thing that we always want to do is we
want to make sure that the water is
boiling before you put the salt in all
right have an idea why no okay so if you
put your salt in before it starts to
boil it will dilute okay and then up
comes the steam and with that steam
comes the salt and so you lose some of
that salt consistency oh the other thing
is you always want to use kosher salt in
all your cooking whether it's pasta or
whether it's anything kosher salt is
very different than table salt it's less
salty and diamond kosher salt is less
salty than morton kosher salt and end of
the day you cannot overcook or over
season with the kosher salt okay so
about how much salt do you think you
want to put into this water and being
that into boiling i should turn it up it
lost its boil those bubbles back bubbles
um you'll get my drift um because what
you want this water to be like is the c
so you're going to use your intuition
and your instincts about how much salt
do you think you would put in if you
were wanting to bring this up to the
seed well i would imagine it's probably
more than i would think so a few scoops
i'm guessing so you would put about two
two to three maybe or three okay are you
gonna tell me all of it
well yeah almost so what i'm going to
tell you is that dilutes and really what
you want to do is you want to go like
this
and that's it and what happens what
happens is is you bring that to a stir
and taste the difference this is a piece
of pasta not cooked with more than two
tablespoons of salt okay and this is one
cooked with what i just threw in taste
the difference
it's only been about two minutes and i'm
already learning so much so thank you
you're
you taste the difference yes and so once
you take this out of the water you can't
correct the seasoning so you always want
to make sure that your pasta is salted
properly okay you also want to reserve
this is pasta water so what you do is
when you drain your pasta before you
drain it you want to reserve about two
cups of pasta water and this is so that
when you take your pasta and this is
olive oil garlic
there's garlic in there let me tell you
eight cloves of garlic and pasta water
is in here okay so let's say you are
making pasta at home and you're using
jarred pasta
what will happen is you oh my god i
should have gotten a
a jar and a half right and you run out
of it it's too dry yeah then what you do
is you add some pasta water
in order to thin it out okay so you
don't want to just use regular water
because it will make it very um
watery yeah i've always heard of using
pasta water but i never knew why so now
i know yes okay so we're going to add to
this okay oh about a pinch and a half or
if you like more of the red chili pepper
and a little flavor yep that's a lot
okay i won't put all that in no one will
be able to eat it okay and then the acid
which is the lemon right and when you
think about a tomato based uh pasta
that's a lot of acid right the cheese is
the fat i like a good cheese we have
about a minute left so we'll get it all
in there together
together okay we're going to toss it up
we got lots of acid everywhere lots of
acid everywhere watch the eyes okay so
now we have uh i think it could use just
a little bit more pasta water what do
you think i i trust you yeah i turn to
you for that no use your in-state trust
your instincts you use it for tv camera
you can use it in the kitchen okay so
we're going to take this and we're going
to pour it let's see is it too hot to
lift nope we're going right into this
beautiful this looks beautiful we're
going to add how about if you grab your
cheese and dump it maybe half of it all
of it in okay whatever you think for
just keep going a little bit more i
think all right
she's the better beautiful parsley there
you go right on top i love it and there
you go
so
you want you can grab a fork yes and as
we're wrapping up here really quick tell
me why it's called midnight pasta
midnight pasta because chefs get home
the urban legend is they get home at
midnight after working all night long
they're hungry and this can be made in
less than five minutes as you can see
especially with leftover pasta you can
just heat it up right i love a good
leftover nanny bobby thank you so much i
can't wait to say goodbye to this and
yeah i see more segments in our future
check out andy bubby's kitchen and
garden on social media and online at
nannybubby.com two three yeah go out and
spread love like butter spread love like
butter